and we turn out of the economy and the
FED facing a very tough decision today
on whether to raise interest rates yet
again in an effort to slow down
inflation it is a consequential call a
difficult call made all the more
difficult by the recent failure of
multiple Banks Ed O'Keefe following it
all for us Ed Good morning Tony good to
see you whatever the FED announces today
comes amid turmoil in the banking sector
following the failure of multiple Banks
this month and experts say the Federal
Reserve is going to need to walk a fine
line to get it right
in the U.S banking system remains sound
treasury secretary Janet Yellen once
again pledging support to smaller Banks
following the collapse of Silicon Valley
Bank and Signature Bank our intervention
was necessary to protect the broader U.S
banking system and similar actions could
be warranted if smaller institutions
suffered deposit runs that pose the risk
of contagion that risk hangs over the
Federal Reserve which is expected to
raise interest rates to try to cool the
economy and combat inflation but with
fresh instability in the banking sector
financial markets are now expecting
maybe hoping for a more modest quarter
percentage Point increase if I were on
the FED I'd recommend no rate increase
Mark zandi Chief Economist at Moody's
Analytics says the FED has a tough job
after the bank failures this month I'm
trying to thread the needle here balance
things trying to do enough to help
support the banking system and financial
system get that on Solid ground but at
the same time continue to fight
inflation the Housing Industry could be
particularly affected by today's
decision Alison goodheart to shuttle
runs a real estate company with her mom
Sue in Northern Virginia and has seen
things cool in the past year as rates
climb she says buyers began getting
priced out and sellers decided to stay
put year over year our Market in the DC
area is down about 20 percent in terms
of closed sales Nationwide existing home
sales actually increased from January to
February but are still down more than 22
percent from last year it appears that
interest rates are going to continue to
rise and if that's the case then it's
better to get the foot in the door now
now here at the White House President
Biden knows the health of the economy
could have big implications for his
political fortunes that's why everyone
here like the rest of us will be
watching this afternoon to see what the
FED decides to do and what chairman
Jerome Powell says about where he thinks
things are headed Vlad
to be continued Ed thank you very much